now Chancellor fair play to you we've
asked people what they thought of your
budget and the reaction social media not
bad not bad at all people seem to
receive this very very well and it was
all going so well and then this happened
and your chairman brand chaps he issues
this image and a lot of people feel very
sort of put out by this bingo cutting
the bingo tax and beer duty to help
hard-working people do more of the
things that they enjoy not and a lot of
folk what would you say to the folk who
would say this is a condescending or to
the the chief secretary of the Treasury
Danny Alexander who has called it rather
patronizing well i would say that
helping the bingo industry and helping
the pub industry where many many
thousands of people work is incredibly
important and these are industries that
declined under the Labor Party under the
Labour government because alcohol tax
went up and up and up and bingo tax was
too high and we've taken these measures
look it is part of a budget that is
supporting work supporting jobs and
helping people and I'm really proud to
be helping to deliver the long-term
economic plan that this government is
delivering that it's turning this
country around bingo for Britain then I
mean I just really don't get best why
why not sort of raise the minimum wage
for instance or cut v80 why you know why
not help the horse racing industry what
why bingo well as it happens I did also
help the horse racing industry by making
sure the offshore bookies make a
contribution to the horse-racing levy
and that's another industry employs many
people though with bingo there are
thousands of people employed in this
industry three-quarters of the bingo
halls have closed in recent years there
at the center of many communities and
you know it is one of the things we're
doing on the only thing but one of the
things we're doing to put right what
went wrong to grow our economy to create
jobs and
economic security for people and that is
what this long-term economic plan is all
about